[Música]
a
honduras es uno de los 12 países
latinoamericanos en mantener su
educación en línea luego de que en abril
del año pasado se cerrará la educación
presencial en escuelas colegios y
universidades a raíz de la pandemia del
2019 sin embargo esta semana próxima el
ministerio de educación autorizó lo que
llaman un pilotaje en 55 escuelas y
colegios de las zonas rurales donde hay
baja densidad poblacional esto a raíz de
la preocupación de la dirigencia
magisterial quienes afirman que el año
pasado de 2 millones de niños
matriculados un millón no terminó en la
escuela por su parte en lo que va de
este año dos de cada tres niños y
jóvenes hondureños no tienen acceso a la
educación en línea dado los bajos
recursos económicos en que vive la
mayoría de la población hondureña y en
donde los padres tienen que elegir entre
comprar internet o la alimentación de
sus hijos
[Música]
en bolivia el sistema educativo es
precario y con la llegada de la pandemia
esta situación ha empeorado recordemos
que el año pasado durante el gobierno
transitorio de jeanine áñez se clausuró
el año escolar dejando a cerca de 3
millones de estudiantes sin acceso a las
clases este año el gobierno de luisa se
ha repuesto la educación formal pero ha
dejado que sea cada escuela la que
decida la modalidad a aplicar que puede
ser presencial semipresencial o virtual
sucede que muchos bolivianos si bien
tienen acceso a internet no tienen cómo
pagar las megas o no tienen dinero para
adquirir los equipos para que sus hijos
asistan a clases virtuales entonces los
dirigentes sociales y sindicales han
estado exigiendo que los maestros
vuelvan a clases por lo menos
semipresencial es y eso ha ocurrido
sobre todo en el área rural y en los
barrios populares donde se han vuelto a
clases semipresenciales pero cuando se
han presentado casos de kobe 19 las
escuelas han sido los mismos maestros
los que han vuelto a cerrar las aulas
dejando a los estudiantes a la deriva en
bolivia sólo el 5 por
ciento de los colegios están gestionados
por el sector privado donde si se ofrece
una educación virtual medianamente
aceptable
[Música]
paraguay está atravesando su peor
momento en la pandemia del coi 19 con
picos de contagio y muertes diarias es
en ese contexto que el gobierno del
presidente mario abdo benítez pretende
mantener un sistema educativo híbrido
recomendando clases presenciales
exclusivamente en las zonas consideradas
rojas por la alta cantidad de casos de
coronavirus de mis docentes y
organizaciones estudiantiles advierten
que además de la crisis sanitaria existe
una falta de infraestructura en las
escuelas y colegios y por eso exigen al
estado que este año la educación sea
exclusivamente a distancia
paradójicamente en un país donde el 70%
de los niños y adolescentes no cuentan
con recursos tecnológicos que les
permitan acceder a una educación virtual
este año el 67 por ciento del alumnado
es decir 892 mil estudiantes secundarios
y primarios se inscribieron a la
modalidad a distancia el año pasado la
irrupción de la educación virtual causó
la deserción escolar de al menos 18.000
niños y adolescentes según cifras
oficiales del gobierno esto fue
considerado por sectores políticos y
sociales como una catástrofe educativa
es por eso que este año el gobierno abdo
benítez pretende mantener contra viento
y marea las clases presenciales
[Música]